we in European Commission myself and
Commissioner Malmstrom we believe that
European Union cannot accept that
thousands of people die at its borders
the challenges that lamb producer and
Italy are facing our European challenges
that image of hundreds of coffins will
never get out of my mind it's something
I think one cannot forget and what I can
promise today is that the Commission
will do all it can with means that we
have to help change in situation and
sonali at odeon on tra que la comisión e
pronta immobilizer a fond d additionally
fino a non massimo di trent emiliani
yellow ancora nel guey mila tre dici
para Atari refuge at in italia